how many faces does the following shape
have pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right i'm assuming you pause it and
i'll see if we can work through it
together and i'm going to actually try
to color the faces
so
we have this face over
oops let me do it in my
this other tool
so you have this face
over here in the back
so that's one face
so that's one
then you have
this face right over here also in the
back
the only way we can see this is because
they've drawn it so that it is
transparent so that is the second face
now you have this triangular face on top
so let me color that in
so you have
this triangular face
on top
so that that's going to be our third
face
third face and then you have this
triangular face on the bottom that's
going to be our fourth face
that's going to be our fourth face and
the key question is are we done looks
like i've colored all the ones that i
can see
but there's one a little bit tricky here
there's the one that we are actually
seeing through
there's the face
there's let me pick a color there's the
face out front that we can see through
so that we can see faces one two and
four so that's actually going to be our
fifth face
the way they've drawn it it's like it's
made out of glass so we can see faces
one two and four but that is our fifth
face
and so this thing has five faces
all right let's do another example but
instead of faces
let's gonna think about we're gonna
think about edges
so how many edges does the following
shape have pause the video and see if
you can work through this
okay let's work through this together
now and i'm just going to count these
edges so the edges are where two faces
meet
so
this is an edge right over there
so that's one edge
there's an edge back here we can see
because it's transparent that is our
second edge
we have this one over here that is our
third edge
we have this one over there
that is our fourth edge
then we have this one over here
that is our fifth
edge
now we have
this here
this is our sixth edge let's see all we
have left is this one
which is edge number seven and then last
but not least this edge over here which
is edge number eight and i actually
found this very valuable to color them
in to make sure that i wasn't missing an
edge or double counting an edge so this
thing has
eight
edges
actually if you're curious just for
extra practice how many faces does this
have
well we can count those as well
this has
one face back there
another face back there so it's two
faces
and then you have a third face which is
the base this rectangular face
so that's three faces and then you have
your two faces out front
you have
this face that we're seeing through
and then we have that face that we're
seeing through so even though they're
asking edges just for practice we
figured out that this thing has five
faces one for the square base and then
four triangular faces for these sides to
make this to make this square pyramid so
it has eight edges and five faces